This is a perfect collision of authenticity from the court, from the game...
...and then you're mixing this up with luxury and craft...
...to a level that has never been done before.
The choices of material, for example,...
...it's a material that we have never used.
When we started doing the Jordan, I was like, it has to be Dior Gray.
It's the Mister Dior color.
And there is this little clin d'oeil to one AJ1 that is the neutral gray.
Basically, it's constructed like a bag.
The leather was Italian, so we have the edge painting as well.
We have a larger Swoosh on ours because we wanted to have the Oblique very visible.
But the best part of it actually is when you take a sock liner out,...
...the Strobel line has the Dior pattern in it as well,...
...so every detail has been truly obsessed.
So, from the get-go, we knew that it can't just stop with the AJ1.
It had to be a full collection,...
...so we created an entire outfit from head to toe.
We went to the archives, both for Dior and Jordan,...
...basically picking the best silhouettes,...
...and the ones that we are each best known for.
The inspiration behind it goes right back to Michael Jordan...
...and what he was wearing on and off the court.
Jordan always had that sophistication as well as that street edge than any other player.